man you guys are not ready for this
comic you guys are not ready for this
and the ending is going to blow your
mind right okay so this is X-Men red as
part of the fall of X event although it
is kind of separate so what we might do
is we might create a playlist
exclusively for X-Men red so it'll be
very easy to get caught up on everything
that's going on here so at the end of
this video If you find yourself feeling
lost make sure you click the link to
that playlist and you'll get caught up
so what this does is this basically
continues the Civil War on Mars that's
one thing to remember that's what's
going on with fall of X on Earth orcus
is attacking the traditional X-Men
groups and mutants that exist on Earth
but on Mars you had a subsect of mutants
here right that just lived here for a
period of time but they're all basically
being eradicated right there's a whole
history behind it and again you know
you'll find out about that in the uh in
the playlist but the long and short is
that war has come to the doorstep of
those mutants that found residency on
Mars at least those surviving mutants
and the reason why I say surviving is
because in the last video that we did
you guys called it right because what
happens here is this picks up with cesah
of the smoke she's basically a mutant
that has the same Powers as Nightcrawler
and where they're supposed to be
evacuating because the four horsemen of
apocalypse right these four Omega Level
mutants whose Powers I will explain as
we get to this video they're the ones
leading this charge against any and all
mutants that exist on Mars wipe them all
out take the planet over that's it right
that's their motivation here what siia
says as cobak right her teammate is
trying to get her out of there she's
like no no no no we can't leave yet
there's something that I have to do
right something that Robert dasta
Sunspot locked away for safekeeping
right after Judgment Day auror storm
usted the night seats to keep an
Ultimate Weapon the uranos trigger you
guys called it man you guys called it
because in the video that we were doing
I'm going to start referencing the
comments for like predictions on what
comes next right what you guys had
predicted is that somewhere along the
line in this war they're going to bring
in uranos now for those of you guys who
don't know what that means this guy is
like a demon right I mean this dude is
this dude's a Hos this guy would
probably Crush Thanos to be honest with
you guys I mean it's it wouldn't even be
close so here's the deal with uranos and
comic book event that happened recently
that we did Cover called Judgment Day
which was basically The Avengers the
eternals and the X-Men all going to war
against each other the eternals had
launched an attack against the mutant
population by releasing uranos and
uranos is just this ridiculously old
Eternal who literally controls just all
these different arms and armaments ships
the whole nine yards but this guy is
just the living embodiment of death when
they released him on Mars within the
span of I'm pretty sure it was 1 hour he
eradicated 98 to
99% of the entirety of the planet's
population which included guys like
Magneto this dude was Next Level
overpowered so at the end of that event
what ended up happening is that a peace
treaty was brokered between the eternals
and the X-Men and as part of this peace
treaty the mutant population was given
the urano trigger so that if some kind
of an event transpired where they needed
assistance they could activate the
trigger and uranos would intervene for 1
hour and that's kind of where they're at
right now right now he talks to like sah
because she's not the one with the
authority to make the decision but what
you do end up doing is switching over to
the four horsemen launching their attack
now these guys are ridiculously
overpowered all four of them are Omega
Level mutants right and here's what
their powers are so death has the
ability to remove his helmet and look
upon anybody and when that happens that
person will die the only way that
doesn't happen is if he looks upon like
a reflective image but he can't be
killed by his own power so if you were
to put a mirror up to his face his
powers would deflect but it wouldn't
actually kill him now War has the
ability to force things to spontaneously
combust basically the ability to not
only control fire but also to make fire
which is not something that you normally
see when it comes to pyrokinesis famine
is a hydrokinetic meaning famine
controls water but the reason why famine
is an Omega Level mutant here is because
there's no limit to how they can control
water and they can actually pull the
water out of human beings and out of any
sentient beings bodies so literally just
turn them to dust and then of course
pestilence fires these arrows that
basically force a person to succumb to
illness disease even die and what
they're doing here is there laying waste
to this entirety right the home base of
where these remaining mutants on Mars
are residing which include storm and
storm is the one who's been like leading
the charge against this Army right a
field commander leader General whatever
you want to call her and what she does
is she says thank you famine today you
showed me who you are and you showed
what Mercy to you brings even a second
of it there will be no more because
These Guys these four Horsemen they're
just killing everybody right there's no
mercy to be found here if you run up to
one of them begging for your life
they're going to kill you right like
that's just the way that it is and so
she literally takes this dude out on the
spot just like that right then you have
War who steps in and says no there will
not right who are you to challenge us
WEA wit you are the spawn of the
powerless we are the children of oro's
greatest power oraco being the dimension
that they come from the kings and queens
of this world we are the true omegas and
we know our worth and storm comes back
dude she claps back with the best line
that I've ever heard right she was like
when the annihilation Helm took Genesis
you did not side with your mother you
sided with the hell so I know your worth
and battle between Omega Level mutants
has never been a matter of power little
flame it's all about versatility this
girl snaps her fingers and says girl you
better comes strong right she's like I
am the weather I am pressure and
temperature I am wind and I am Whirlwind
I am many things War you are one thing
you are fire what are you when the fire
leaves she literally uses the power of
wind and pressure to just siphon the
power out of the girl right just take
her out on the spot that just needs to
be stated here in the span of about a
minute and a half storm took took out
two Omega Level mutants which is no
small feet these are mutants with a
level of power that dwarfs virtually
anybody else around them and I got to
tell you man I love what Al huming is
doing with storm because For the first
time in a long time it feels like she's
overpowered right then death steps in
and that's where things start to get
scary because this guy is not to be
trifled with death is not a guy to be
messed with but here's the kicker about
it right because of the power that he
has he doesn't just like run in take off
his helmet and just show it to everybody
and just kill everybody in existence
this guy is all about Pomp and
Circumstance right this guy is all about
the honor of the battle and that's why
he challenges storm to one-on-one combat
now this is one of the things that makes
him so interesting but deadly at the
same time because it's like the Dallas
Cowboys playing against any team in the
NFL they're going to lose that's just
how it is and so when you have death
showing up to you and challenging you
your death is pretty much guaranteed the
kicker about this is pestilence steps in
and pestilence fires an arrow at storm
now in that moment Richard Ryder Nova
who's just kind of been working
alongside the mutant population on Mars
for quite some time he's kind of like
their uh liaison to space fairing alien
Empire as that exist out there this guy
jumps in the way and he's hit with the
arrow and starts succumbing to
pestilence now at that moment storm
steps in to try to like touch him and
try to like get him out of there right
to fly him away and death says no do not
touch him if you touch him the plague
will spread to you and it will kill you
right and then at that point he turns on
his sister now that's the thing about
death he's not doing this because he's
just like has the hots for storm I mean
he does right and let's be honest with
ourselves man who wouldn't right if
storm was a real person yeah man she'd
have like 10 million followers on
Instagram with a whole bunch of bikini P
but the thing about this is he is all
about the honor of it that's what
matters to him the most and pestilence
betrayed that honor pestilence betrayed
what they stand for honorable combat
having an honorable challenge against
somebody else and so he removes his
helmet and she succumbs to his power and
literally just disintegrates and that's
the Fate that would have awaited storm
right there would have been nothing she
could have done to stop it and so in
this moment right this brief reprieve
that that's when you have cesiah who
shows up and cesiah gives storm the
uranos trigger and she says here you
take it you're the one with the
authority to make the decision on what
we do I'm tired of listening to this and
that's when uranos starts talking to
storm and he says we meet again auror
Monroe I've been watching your situation
so I won't Preamble it is as I told
cesiah release me and within my hour of
freedom I will end your War by ending
every single life on this planet that is
not of your faction the trigger is in
your hands the choice is yours choose
now if she chooses it would be exactly
as uros says he will show up here
everybody who's not on the side of storm
will die that's just the way it's going
to be here's the kicker to this ladies
and gentlemen we switch over to the
Autumn lands once home to the Autumn
Palace on Mars and the Ken gate opens up
and as we know the Ken Gates allow
individuals to travel from other
dimensions into any other location where
a gate is active a voice simply ask the
question here and then this person says
dead lifeless Rock but with a sun caged
below it imprisoned abandoned a useful
ingredient and with the storm coming to
meet us for or where else can she turn
yes here here we will remake the world
ladies and gentlemen the real apocalypse
has returned not the one that we saw the
projection that we saw in the immortal
X-Men comic that we recently covered
this is the real apocalypse and the
questions got to be asked ladies and
gentlemen what happens cuz you know it's
going to happen what happens when
apocalypse fights uranos I can't wait
until that comic comes out but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end if you need to get caught
up on X-Men red make sure you click this
link to the playlist and I will catch
you all later peace